parce que nos villes se transforme
perpétuellement nous avons le devoir de
recycler tous ces matériaux yprema votre
partenaire pour un développement durable
bonjour et bienvenue dans équilibre le
magazine de l'environnement et du
développement durable
au sommaire de ce numéro le maraîcher
robert pires et notre coup de coeur de
la saison nous sommes allés une nouvelle
fois sa rencontre pour tirer un premier
bilan de son exploitation
le projet que tout charge coordonnée par
wade énergie et services est une
renforcement de l'infrastructure
recharge des véhicules électriques
le démonstrateur se trouve à bout
challenger l'eau au golf national est
une question cruciale pour garantir un
terrain parfait aux pratiquants la
structure s'est engagé depuis plusieurs
années dans une politique de gestion
éco-responsable
nous l'avions rencontré pour la première
fois au mois de février robert pirès
maraîcher installé à magny les hameaux
depuis le début de l'année est
maintenant en pleine activité sur son
terrain bilan de ces premiers mois
d'exploitation avec notre coup de coeur
de la saison 2014 2015
le terrain a déjà bien changé en ce
début du mois de juillet robert pirès
cultive salades choux raves courgettes
ou encore tomates en février dernier ce
maraîcher avait vu son installation
prendre forme avec l'aide de plusieurs
bénévoles
cinq mois plus tard il propose déjà des
produits
je crois que le monde est content pour
moi en tout cas je le suis et les
retours que j'ai des gens aussi dans
l'ensemble ism.l'ism le goût des coûts
des légumes
donc ça ça tient pas à moi c'est ça veut
dire que la terre répond bien
ils ne sont pas gros mais légumes parce
que j'ai un une problématique d'arrosage
très limité mais du coup le goût lui il
est pas mal et on est assez content et
la quantité
je crois que c'est bien aussi
actuellement robert pirès fourni deux
amap l'une à magny les hameaux la
seconde dans le xviiie arrondissement de
paris
il livre une quarantaine de paniers
chaque semaine on vote un peu lapin mais
j'aime bien j'ai démarré de manière
précaires on va le dire pour pouvoir
démarrer vite j'arrose soit l'arrosoir
sur des petites surfaces cultivées soi
où vous tenez uniquement et donc je ne
peux pas beaucoup arrosé je ne peux pas
beaucoup mouillé mais plan mais mais du
coup c'est quelque chose qui pour
l'instant gelé remarquer gérable même
même depuis plus d'un mois où il n'y a
quasiment pas eu d'eau
simplement ça ne me permettra pas de
grandir la surface exploitée pour
augmenter mais le nombre de paniers en
faire quelque chose de rentable en
quelque sorte permet de tirer un revenu
actuellement vous vivez de votre
exploitation non non parce que je
cherche d'abord en fait à pérenniser
mon activité c'est à dire donc j'achète
ce dont j'ai besoin
donc aujourd'hui mes revenus sont
entièrement réinvestis dans ce qui est
dans ce qui est achats dans ce qui est
un investissement sûr d'une sur du
matériel plutôt du petit matériel mais
tout de même donc aujourd'hui je cherche
pas forcément à en vivre en tout cas
pour cette année j'ai démarré en milieu
d'année ce qui n'est pas banal et
complète donc s'il vous dire je veux
sortir un remix pour améliorer la
gestion de l'eau un chantier pour
acheminer celle de la ville va être
lancé d'ici la fin du mois de juillet
robert pirès cultive pour le moment près
de 8000 m² de terrain sur l'année il
faut proposer une quarantaine de légumes
de 80 variétés différentes
le 13 mai dernier élit dray pour la
première fois la marque mangold
un tracteur fonnière rien qu'à st
c'est émouvant et à quelque chose de
l'émouvant dans cette dans cette
première distribution
parce que les légumes sont là parce
qu'ils sont arrivés il avait même
plusieurs semaines d'avancé avec avec la
chaleur et je suis très content de
pouvoir pouvoir fournir 1
un beau panier pour pour cette première
distribution aux amapiens de manille et
château pour une cagnotte solidaire
avait été lancée en février par
l'association le bonheur est dans le pré
4600 euros ont déjà pu être récoltés ce
prêt a notamment permis à robert pirès
d'investir dans un tracteur dans cette
aventure le maraîcher n'était donc pas
tout seul un élan de solidarité qui
l'encouragent à poursuivre son activité
qu'on peut dire aujourd'hui que vous
êtes complètement épanoui dans cette
reconversion je me pose pas la question
tous les jours en jours mais moi je veux
je crois que je suis heureux
développer l'utilisation des véhicules
électriques c'est l'un des défis du
projet eco tout charge mais pour cela il
faut que les infrastructures répondent
présentes notamment pour recharger les
batteries direction oui challenger qui
héberge le projet démonstrateur pour
comprendre toutes les problématiques que
soulève ce mode de transport
nous sommes avec servant la cire bonjour
bonjour vous êtes le directeur
l'innovation technologique de huy
énergie et services
tout d'abord et quoi tout charge de quoi
s'agit-il alors que vous de charge d'un
programme de développement et de
recherche que nous menons avec des
partenaires pour faciliter
l'installation et le déploiement des
interprètes les infrastructures de
recharge du véhicule électrique
vous me parlez de partenaires qui sont
ils alors nous avons lu partenaires
activity alstom bouygues énergie et
services
le cea nbc est une filiale commune
alstom bouygues immobilier et bouyer
nager et services nexans renault bien
sûr et université de versailles saint
quentin en yvelines
aujourd'hui où en est le projet le
projet est aux deux tiers de son chemin
donc nous commençons à voir des produits
ou des solutions à paraître en test et
qu'on espère pour certaines pouvoir
commercialiser à la fin du projet et
concrètement comment cela va-t-il
fonctionner concrètement le projet est
en porte sur deux volets un volet qu'est
la gestion intelligente de la recherche
du véhicule électrique sur le site
en tenant compte des besoins des usagers
ça sert quels éléments importants l'idée
c'est de dire quand j'ai récemment sur
mon psy pour recharger mon véhicule
électrique
je le gars je l'oubli le temps je suis
sur le site je n'ai plus à me préoccuper
quand je repars il est chargé mais c'est
aussi pour éviter d'avoir à doubler
l'infrastructure du site
parce que tout le monde arrivera à 9
heures du matin tout le monde arrive en
2 heures du matin il faudrait recharger
tout le monde en même temps c'est de
gérer la recharge du véhicule électrique
en fonction des prévisions de production
d'énergie renouvelable dans la journée
en fonction des prévisions de
consommation du site dans la journée la
surêté hiver c'est pas forcément la même
chose il faut soit aussi du besoin des
usagers donc il ya plusieurs volets il
ya une partie gestion intelligente de
l'infrastructure qui va
les ordres et communiquer avec véhicules
et donner l'énergie nécessaire et puis
il ya un système de gestion d'énergie
globale sur le site qui lui va tenir
compte des prévisions de production des
prévisions de consommation des
prévisions besoins des usagers comme un
juré de véhicules qui vont arriver sur
le site et quels sont leurs besoins pour
optimiser des tarifs pour optimiser la
recharge au niveau du site et optimiser
la consommation globale de l'énergie
électrique sur le site dans ce projet il
ya aussi la question de batterie est ce
que vous pouvez nous en dire un peu plus
alors le deuxième volet de ce projet et
c'est l'utilisation de l'énergie de
pouvoir stocker l'énergie électrique
ce projet est basé sur la réutilisation
de batteries de véhicules électriques
une fois qu'elles ont atteint leurs
limites de capacité pour le véhicule
électrique le constructeur estime qu'à
peu près entre 70 et 80% de la capacité
initiale de la batterie n'est plus
utilisable pour le véhicule électrique
parce que ses capacités de du pro bass
elle a quand même plusieurs années
d'utilisation ce que nous tests ont
montré sur les sites pourquoi la être
utilisés décès de dire je la démens du
véhicule électrique sans avoir l'air
conditionné j'utilise tel quel
je la mets sur notre système et à partir
de là on peut l'utiliser pour charger et
décharger de l'énergie électrique donc
la batterie connecter un système que
nous avons développé avec renault pour
piloter la recherche de l'énergie
électrique au niveau des infrastructures
ce à un coût important pour une
entreprise qui voudraient se lancer là
dedans un coût important oui et non
si vous n'avez pas à refaire au tableau
distribution et où la distribution
le coup est modéré bodéré il faut quand
même acheté la borne ça fait un millier
d'euros pour mettre quelques câbles pour
l'alimenter même avec le système des
levures annexion ça représente un tout
petit peu d'argent mais on parle d'eux
2000 euros par borne on parle pas de
10000 euros par borne par contre si vous
faire toute la distribution et refaire
l'abonnement edf vers des fc coûte un
peu plus cher est dans la question quand
le projet pourrait être mis en service
le projet arrive à échéance milieu
d'année prochaine
bien sûr il est prévu que très
rapidement des solutions des partitions
projet soit mise en service les
batteries de seconde vie nous avons déjà
des clients pilotes qui sont qui
demandent elles vont être déployés dans
le cadre du projet issygrid dans elles
sont déployées dans un site erdf drapeau
de distribution au public
nous avons d'autres clients pilotes qui
voudraient les tester elles vont être
industrialisé à travers un projet
européen que nous avons emporté avec
renault nissan et des partenaires
européens pour industrialiser système
est il le tester dans 6 pays européens
et puis les solutions de distribution
intelligente de l'énergie sursis seront
commercialisés trappe merci savoir la
cire toutes ces explications n'ont pu y
avoir un terrain à la hauteur de la
technicité de son parcours est un enjeu
pour le golf national pour entretenir
les 139 hectares de terrains la
structure a adopté depuis quelques
années une politique éco-responsable
dans la gestion de l'eau un sujet
préparé avec sephora namani et maxime le
même entretenir le parcours de façon
écoresponsable une priorité pour le golf
national
en 2006 la fédération française de golf
a signé une charte avec les ministères
de l'écologie et des sports elle
s'engage à réduire notamment
l'utilisation de l'ordre de 20% par an
la première des choses à faire c'est de
raisonner les graminées qu'on va
utiliser puisque c'est quand même le
choix qu'ont effectué en amont et en
fonction des graminées qu'on va
amenez implantée sur le site on n'aura
pas du tout les mêmes besoins en nous
une graminée comme la fétuque on
implante dans l'erreur au maximum
actuellement est une graminée qui
nécessitent peu d'eau alors que les
agrostide qu'on peut trouver sur les
greens ou voir même le pâturin annuel
est certain les gras sont beaucoup plus
voraces ou demandeur en eau l'eau est
stockée dans des grands bassins
ils permettent notamment de ramener
l'eau à température ambiante 900
arroseurs sont actuellement en place
pour hydrater le parcours des travaux de
modernisation du système de drainage ont
été engagés à l'issue de l'open de
france qui s'est terminée le 5 juillet
les arroseurs ben change sont de plus en
plus performants on a des têtes de plus
en plus petits avec des jets qu'on peut
gérer au mieux pour des brumisations
pour et puis du coup on va pouvoir via
les deux mises arroseurs qu'on va
implanter
on va pouvoir procéder à des arrosages
beaucoup plus et beaucoup mieux
circonscrit et donc pour une efficacité
accrue et des économies d'eau à terme
les équipes du golfe viste aussi à
couper le gazon à bonne hauteur et à
l'arroser avec parcimonie des techniques
suffisamment maîtriser pour être
efficace sans perturber le jeu des
golfeurs on arrive à un résultat
équivalent pour le golfeur le golf est
tout aussi beau
peut-être différent peut-être qu'il ya
un petit peu plus d'herbe d'herbe marron
jaune mais ça c'est en saison d'été
uniquement des kirs plein hiver s'est
ouvert aujourd'hui soixante mille mètres
cubes d'eau sont nécessaires pour
arroser les 139 ha du golf national
la structure a réalisé une économie de
40 mille mètres cubes par an depuis la
signature de la charte
et comme chaque mois je vous propose
quelques rendez-vous l'allègue de saint
quentin en yvelines vous lance un
nouveau défi après les éco-gestes c'est
au tour de votre maison d'être sous le
feu des projecteurs avec le concours
maisons économes 2015 les inscriptions
se font jusqu'au 14 septembre
vos enfants ont entre 6 et 10 ans et des
envies d'évasion nature l'île de loisirs
compose de séjour au mois d'août avec
des nuls dont les tipis et les journées
consacrées notamment aux soins à faire
aux animaux de la ferme pédagogique et
pour bien finir les vacances vous
pourrez découvrir l'étang de saint
quentin en yvelines en visite commentée
en canoë ça se passe le samedi 29 août
de 14h30 à 17h voilà équilibre c'est
terminé je vous souhaite de passer un
très bel été et d'ici là
pensez à faire un geste pour
l'environnement